gives you a modern filter plus rich
tobacco tastes hard to imagine now video
adverts promoting the benefits of
smoking
thanks to tough government policy
taxation and health campaigns the number
of people smoking in the UK has fallen
from 27 percent to 17 percent over the
last 20 years
in short smoking has become a social
taboo it's still the country's biggest
killer
but there's another close behind obesity
two-thirds of the population are
overweight or obese and this is the
government strategy to tackle it while
it's welcomed as a step forward critics
say that it's lacking in structure that
it focuses on children rather than
adults and is heavily reliant on
voluntary action from the junk food
manufacturers prompting calls for a
stricter approach professor Robert West
specializes in smoking research he says
the government could learn a lot from
the anti tobacco strategy to get to
grips with obesity to the extent that we
can incentivize companies that are
producing highly calorie dense foods to
produce foods that are healthier and to
market their foods in a way that is more
conducive to a healthy diet then you can
start to tackle the problem without that
it's always going to be an uphill
struggle so could we see health warnings
on junk food packaging chocolate and
sweets kept hidden behind shutters not
quite getting tough on the stock
industry isn't as easy as with tobacco
we can all survive without tobacco we
can't survive without food and there's
so many different products so yes the
government can go further but it also
needs to frankly work with the it can't
make the food and drink industry as it
has with the tobacco industries the
sugar tax brought in last year has shown
that food manufacturers are willing to
adapt here at the Nestle Research Centre
in York they've been finding new ways of
making chocolate that isn't as sweet
[Music]
that's in
times have changed a lot since this
advert Nestle's Milky Bar now hailed for
having 30% less sugar and far from being
unhappy with the latest government
initiatives Nestle are calling for them
to be stronger I think it would be good
for us to create a level playing field
and the voluntary approach obviously has
its benefits and it's obviously work to
a certain extent and but actually we
might also need to lift out a
combination of voluntary and what a more
regulation the government has set some
ambitious targets but so far there's
been a lot of rhetoric and not enough
results so what next
we have seen some very significant
improvements in reductions in for
example in cereals for children and some
yogurts but on the whole we haven't
achieved that the target of 5 percent
which the government had set come have
been very clear this year but if they
fail to see continued progress and
increased progress in respect of that
sugar reduction that they will take
further action and we really welcome
that no elaboration on exactly what that
further action might be with obesity
rates at epidemic levels in the UK it
will need more than diet and exercise to
bring them down
Charlotte Lomas Sky News